großeinsatz der polizei schwer bewaffnet
haben wir dort polizisten polizist innen
gesehen wie sie auf ein hochhaus zielen
auf ein jobcenter das gebäude komplett
umstellt dann marschieren plötzlich
hunderte polizisten rein hier sehen wir
noch mal die szene eine polizistin mit
ihrer waffe zielt sie auf dieses
hochhaus auf diesen job center da kann
man rein gucken von außen auch wenn es
dunkel war durch das glas ziemlich viel
aufregung sehr viel blaue licht da geht
irgendwann die polizei dieses
spezialeinsatzkommando dort rein in das
gebäude unsere reporter waren da haben
das verfolgt aber dann war nicht richtig
klar erkennbar was war das jetzt was war
das für ein großeinsatz der dort hamburg
so lange in atem gehalten hat in den
späten abendstunden das wollen wir jetzt
wissen von unserem bild hamburg reporter
0 altendorf grüß dich nur hell
was war los hallo es
ist wohl so gewesen dass um 20 uhr 32
zeugen aus dem auto heraus einen mann
beobachtet haben der eine screen home
maske trug und hier vor diesen job
center in rothenburgsort stadtteil stand
und dann auch eine pistole durch lud und
offenbar in das gebäude gegen das
versetzte die männer natürlich in angst
und schrecken und sie riefen die polizei
minuten später waren waren auch dutzende
einsatzkräfte darunter spezialkräfte
hier vor ort und begannen noch sofort
das gebäude zu umstellen und
durchsuchten es dann auch dabei waren
auch hunde im einsatz
das ganze dauerte hier wirklich fünf
stunden bis hier in warnung gegeben
werden konnte weil niemand im gebäude
aufgefunden wurde was jetzt genau
hintergrund dieses mannes ist er hier
beobachtet wurde ist jetzt noch völlig
unklar das ermittelt die polizei also
großeinsatz weil ein mann dort so
schildern des augenzeugen sohnes cream
so eine horror maske auf hatte
möglicherweise also ein ganz ganz
schlechter halloween scherz der diesen
fünf stunden großeinsatz ausgelöst hat
nur
ja so könnte es natürlich sagen hier
beginnt jetzt auch das halloween
wochenende wird diversen partys wir
hatten auch die vergangenen tagen
meldungen über angeblich bewaffnete
personen hamburg die dann auch keine
erkenntnisse weiter brachten aber man
muss natürlich sagen dass damit nicht zu
scherzen ist mit solchen sachen das
zieht kräfte hier aus hamburg ab die
woanders dringend benötigt werden